holy crap that is so awesome it's so
quick but yeah you knew this was coming
pete
spider-man no way home trailer 2 easter
eggs and breakdown reaction from us
today for new rock stars last night
during our live stream eric voss
actually chimed in and said that he had
just finished his script for his
breakdown which i think he was really
trying to say was guys make sure to
react to my breakdown because you don't
know what you're talking about this live
stream really yeah but guys before we go
into this reaction we have a very
important shout out we have to do this
is of most important and that is epic
hero shop you guys have probably seen me
wear this shirt a bunch throughout the
year you've probably seen john wear this
shirt a bunch you've probably seen me
wear that one in a different color and
he's wearing this one in a different
color
and you guys probably seen me wear this
one a bunch too and you know what they
are extremely extremely comfortable
shirts i cannot emphasize that enough
and i get complimented on them all the
time because they are awesome shirts and
they have even more designs and the
reason we are being asked to shout them
out which i wish they had told us this
before we had made a purchase this week
you guys know that black friday and
cyber monday are coming up so they're
gonna of course have a holiday sale but
no no no not just on those days it's
gonna be a cyber week sale seriously you
should have told me this before we
bought some and it starts this coming
monday the 22nd just in time for hawkeye
i wonder if they're gonna release
something for that look it goes without
saying all right here's a talking point
they specialize in all kinds of unique
custom designs celebrating all corners
of nerd culture if you're all familiar
with them you know that's very true and
what's most exciting is they're bringing
back a whole bunch of their lost and
discontinued latest obsession designs so
if you missed one now's the time to
swipe it up just like the loki gator
polo and they're even doing a new
addition the loki gator mark ii so yeah
from this coming monday the 22nd through
the 29th of november there's going to be
15 off discount sale and there's going
to be a brand new line of epic stocking
stuffers wow that's a hard thing to say
for holiday shoppers that's right people
items will include nerdy neckties pet
accessories sucks and even engraved
gifts for someone you love 3 000 iron
man reference i'm telling you guys find
the perfect holiday gift for your
favorite nerd at epic heroshop.com where
epicheroshop.com epic hero shop.com
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of the new
trailer for spider-man no way home which
confronts tom hall and peter parker with
doc ock alfred molina from spider-man
2004 green goblin norman osborn willem
dafoe from the raimi trilogy electro
jamie foxx from the 2014 amazing
spider-man 2 sandman thomas eden church
from the rainy movies and the lizard
rhys hyphens from the 2012 amazing
spider-man not to mention dr strange
but the trailer seems to be playing some
vfx trickery because i highly doubt
peter's facing all these threats by
himself that's right his backup sanic
and track of course i gotta say we did a
two and a half hour live stream and the
lizard has never been more popular in
our entire lives holy crap three minute
trailer this is what most people were
talking about was that one shot right
there one shot from from an obscure
video on brazilian sony twitter the fans
are amazing amazing spider fans let's
get started
ever since i got bit by that spider
i've only had one week
where my life has felt normal
that was when you found out we open on
sad peter parker his face bruised and
bleeding tears and rain seems like the
end of the movie so who is peter morning
who's gonna die well the trailer
suggests mj but it could just as easily
be like ned aunt may happy hogan
probably all of them this could also be
an indian word
in order to save those he loves and
those he doesn't want to harm must exile
himself to a reality in the multiverse
where he is a stranger with no way home
where it rains a lot
peter between her finding out that he
was spider-man and apart from home and
mysterio and j john and jameson outing
him in the post-credits in that movie
was his one normal week ever since the
spider bit him now this is only the
second time peter has mentioned his
spider bite an origin we never actually
saw in the mcu just kind of glossed over
in homecoming no way home could finally
be the film the mcu flashes back to the
exact circumstances of peter's spider
bite especially if this movie does
introduce him to the toby maguire and
andrew garfield versions of the
character whose bites and web slinging
abilities took alternate forms well
actually i think that's what the purpose
of that spider-man freshman year show is
supposed to be right and the same as his
first year spider-man that's right so
perhaps that'll actually show us in an
animated format the way we wanted to
really see it tom holland spider-man
animated we don't want to see it in a
live action it's been done too many
times and not enough times in television
medium format peter and mj swing past
jonah jameson's daily vehicle broadcast
until it switches to his own face half
mast with public enemy number one number
one does no one care that nexus witches
exist just go talk to those survivors in
westview or to mr dell
you know being a man of science
witches and in the shot you can see how
mj's hair is blocking peter's view and
that nearly causes him to smack right
into that screen and only when it clears
does he finally whip to the side
you can see over to the side there this
is right next to the roosevelt island
tramway the setting of green goblin
showdown with tobey maguire
spider-man film let's move on
[Music]
when you botched that spell where you
wanted everyone to forget the peter
parker spiderman
we started getting some visitors
as peter and mj jump from that bridge
you can see mj is wearing the same joan
of our t-shirt that she wore at the end
far from home which in addition to being
a reflection of mj's feminine pride was
itself an easter egg holly back
zendaya's joan of arc look at the 2018
met gala then they glide through the
subway tunnels somehow missing morbius
despite his best efforts to sneak into
this universe and obviously they do this
to escape the helicopters tracking them
and to find andrew peters dad's lap i
could see morbius shoehorning spider-man
into theirs though having spider-man and
zendaya swinging past morbius and then
just have a reverse shot of him being
like wow who are those guys wow i hope
we meet who are you hi i'm i'm venom
michael morbius at your service
it's my water eggs as they nearly run
into a train for a brief second the
train screen flashes red and m the m
train that's right spider-man narrowly
avoided the mebisto train
spider-man we all float down here
[Music]
all right earbuds no mine actually runs
through queens so this train is likely
good what about queens and peter's just
trying to get home but there's no way
home thank you
audio sound stitched together here oh
yeah when you botched that spell where
you wanted everyone to forget the peter
parker spider-man as many of his
off-screen lines actually sound in this
trailer there are others out there we
need to send them back they're starting
to come through
and i can't stop them this is the first
time for me in the marvel universe
i'm guessing that cumberbatch is just so
fluid with slime reads with more
revelatory terms bleeding into the
trailer dialogue making it harder to cut
around now the from behind shot of peter
shows him wearing a dark blue jacket
clearly a different scene than the shot
of peter with the plaid shirt oh good
catch yeah it actually matches with the
shot of the first trailer where the
lizard was swiping at peter so doctor
strange may have actually caught the
lizard on his own while peter was
dealing with doc rock and goblin on the
bridge oh interesting yeah moment that
peter tampers with the spell causing the
golden bands to tremble and then explode
outward and again there are four of
these bands maybe four each of the four
universes that get crossed over in this
movie the mcu the rainy verse the
webverse and the venomverse and as they
illuminate the room you can see that the
blue merc that previously surrounded
them dissipates presumably that was
going to be the cold and drowsy humor
that the doctor strange was trying to
conjure to just simply erase people's
memories but now the golden reality warp
bands tear the room to pieces around
them now that we've seen venom let there
be carnage that movie's post credit
scene seems to be showing a similar
process a bright golden light fills the
room and then reality warps the room's
decor that could explain why we have all
these random odds and ends in this
dungeon later on it's just a bunch of
crap that got redecorated after the
reality worked i compared this imagery
to one to maximoff's reality warping in
one division and i still believe strange
might be under wanda's spell which is
clearly what one vision was setting up
and could explain why strange so
willingly helps peter warp reality
because remember wanda is looking for a
reality where her children could still
be alive that's actually one of the best
there is i've ever heard especially when
you're thinking about how every single
time the marvel movies always have two
post credits scenes one that sets up the
sequel for the title character and
another that sets up some other movie
and presumably this will be for doctor
strange multiverse and madness and then
if they have some type of revelation of
that caliber that one is controlling him
that would be a damn awesome reveal
yeah strange is just himself but a
little sus until the very end when it's
revealed oh no one it was wanda all
along
all along then they guest star in the
disney plush show agatha
house of hearts
from every
universe
[Music]
hello peter i love it green goblin is
here he looms in through the smoke of
his own pumpkin grenades riding his
glider meanwhile strange explains that
these are
coming from every universe meaning
doctor strange might have been
previously aware of alternate universes
like the raimi verse which would give
interesting meaning to the line he said
to tony stark back in infinity war
protecting your reality douchebag then
electro's bolts blast through the ground
toward peter who wears this new black
and gold suit this suit's kind of a mess
there's loose wires poking out duct tape
all over the place actually later you
can see mj
duct tape to his chest apparently
facetiming all this i am guessing this
mission might be to catch electro and
they have to do it in a way without
peter's iron spider armor maybe by
turning his old suit inside out so all
the wiring is now exposed or maybe his
nanotech suit can't be relied on after
he ran into doc ock or this could just
be a new suit that they rigged up to be
more resistant to high voltage damn you
guys have some good eyes there were
people on our live chat who kept saying
mj and ned duct taped to chess i i was
like scouring the footage like what are
they talking about
it was right there the whole time oh i
love that attention to detail of we got
to take on a lecture so i'm assuming he
might have a fight with electro earlier
on where he probably gets messed up that
we don't see it all in the trailers and
so then this suit has to come into play
in order to take him down absolutely
there could be a lot of fun in games
that happens with like oh we need to do
something new to take this dude down i
don't know yeah doc ock or not maybe not
doc seems like he's successfully mad
just to imprison him but especially like
characters like elektra that's gonna be
a lot of fun
you're not peter parker
ah yes license plates so i pointed out
in past videos how the cars on this
bridge seems to have specific license
plates that could be pointing to
specific comic book issues
director john watts actually does in all
of his movies here doc and peter passed
a plate reading
jnd79wn which doesn't seem to directly
translate to anything in particular
unless maybe you try to stretch j and d
being for jessica drew spider-woman or
who did first appear in marvel comics in
nightly i'll take it i'll take it
later here is a clearly overt one asm
8183 johnny spider-man asm to refer to
amazing spider-man and then a specific
comic book issue followed by the year
but this could be interpreted a couple
different ways actually there was a
spectacular spider-man not amazing
spider-man issue 81 in 83 which mixes up
spider-man with cloak and dagger
punisher and a certain bald baddie who's
gonna come stomping into bmcu soon shrek
i mean kingpin yes i'm sure that kingpin
wilson fisk could be revealed in hawkeye
and could be the sixth villain of the
sinister six in this movie i don't think
they're gonna put kingpin in this movie
i just don't believe it i think there's
already too much going on right now and
usually kingpin he's someone who is kind
of hiring the or sourcing out the
sinister six and then it kind of just
adds this whole kind of convoluted layer
i think if you're introducing the
multiverse everything went wrong with
bringing the villains over here so then
what kingpin kind of steps in and goes
huh these villains are here let me just
immediately start sticking them on to
spider-man
and then and get here to get to the fun
and games in action by act two like it
just seems like it'd be way too much
it'd be a little far far-fetched yeah it
would be a crazy plan to have just fall
into his lap like that although with
matt murdock i at least gotta imagine
you could get a hint of his presence but
then beneath the bridge doc jams his
claw at peter and i love how john watts
uses a whip pan the same kind of camera
movement that sam raimi would often use
for doc in the 2004 film but notice how
doc ock's arms now have a red and gold
coating to them and a chunk of peter's
nanotech is missing from his chest he
actually has to reallocate the nanobots
from his helmet to his chest to protect
himself from the blow in a later trailer
shot shows that doc ock straight up
absorbs peter's nanotech armor from his
suit and this is crazy because doc ock
comes from an alternate universe where
stark tech does not exist how can it be
compatible with this tech well if you
think about it his arms are actually
controlled via a neural link that was
fused to a spinal cord and stark
nanotech seems to be controlled via a
kind of neural link as well so maybe
that is how doc ock can hack into it i'm
just excited to see nanotech on the
loose in the mcu could be a major plot
point in shows like armor wars also a
little vfx detail that i appreciate
peter's necktie dangles from the
nanotech hole where his chest is but as
that nanotech shifts and seals that hole
it tucks the necktie back in i mean one
thing i've been hearing about the
nanotech is that actually because of the
neural link that doc has that maybe the
arms of taking control of him again and
that's why he's after the events of
spider-man 2 where he's had this
redemption moment he's come to jesus
moment and basically oh that's why he's
probably going after who he thinks is
toby mcguire peter parker because the
arms are back in control so maybe the
nano attack kind of acts on its own yeah
to take over and then regain him back to
his consciousness his normal self and
that's why he takes a moment to step
step back and go wait a minute you're
not yeah it's like maybe it goes in and
then and then it assesses his genes or
whatever was like wait something's wrong
here something's like over it ridden
your system let us fix this yeah it
gives him back his real personality
which is amazing technology
he could do anything in that nanotech
anything at all meanwhile when tom
holland's face is revealed doc ock says
you're not peter parker answering our
questions from the first trailer as to
why doc would see this version of
spider-man and recognize him as peter
from his universe it's just because doc
ock saw someone i guess who looked like
spider-man and assumed that would be
toby's face underneath but what i like
about this line is it does confirm the
existence of a tobey maguire peter
parker's son
even more likely
i'm sorry what was your name again dr
otto octavius
[Laughter]
wait no seriously what's your actual
name
sounds like the kids are okay boomerang
doc ock about his name i like how ned is
holding a crossbow might have been
something he picked up from strange and
wong's artifacts that they use for
things like vampire hunting because we
know a lot of these are coming in the
mcu meanwhile mj's necklace i love this
detail it's actually a broken piece of
the black dahlia necklace that peter
brown oh no
later ended up broken when he gave it to
her in that movie she's so loyal what a
keeper but i mean it's mj she likes it
better than it's broken and then here we
see how doc actually retains the red and
gold nanobots from peter's suit on his
arms he might have actually absorbed all
of the nanobots for all we know and then
as doc turns his head these claws like
snakeheads turn their heads too we're
not really sure how much these arms are
listening to him or he's listening to
them i like to think they listen to me
now
i gotta say too you know something that
i don't think enough people were
pointing out a lot of people were kind
of gawking at when doc hogg first showed
up in the in the teaser trailer and how
they're like ah the cgi looks really off
on his face and while there are parts in
the fight sequence that look a little
bit off in the in the freeway moment i
think the close-up shots on alfred luna
here look exceptionally well done pretty
flawless for the most part like i didn't
notice it so much to the point that
we're not even calling attention to the
fact of how good it looks now oh yeah
absolutely if you see a regular looking
shot and you're just like oh yeah that's
in camera that's fine yeah i don't
realize just how much work probably went
into that especially with the tentacles
and whatever subtle de-aging they must
have done we pointed out what it looks
like [ __ ] but we don't point it out when
it looks great hashtag dave
there are others out there we need to
send them back
so
scooby doo this crap you know all this
is kind of your mess i know a couple of
magic words myself starting with the
word please
please
scooby-doo this crap okay amazing set
piece here the freaking statue of
liberty keeping the tradition of
landmark set pieces like the washington
monument the venice grand canal tower
bridge in london but now with huge
cranes over it attaching a massive
captain america shield you can see a
banner hanging from the scaffolding
reading lady liberty the newest avenger
and you can actually see those words on
a bus stop ad for it later on now we
just saw liberty island used as an
example of how the world has gone to
crap during the blip with all the loose
boats moored up to it but now it seems
as though the government is using lady
liberty as a way of celebrating the
avengers victory for when cap stood his
ground facing the abyss and found backup
from opening portals behind him as we
pray peter parker will receive some
backup from other peters in this scene
if you remember this was kind of
foreshadowed and far from home when
mysterio's illusion trapped peter in a
snow globe where the statue of liberty
rose up oh cool and earlier
among giant statues of his fallen
avenger heroes with him standing on a
giant captain america's shield now of
course
the final battle set piece has been
something that pretty much all superhero
movies have avoided because it was done
back in one of the first big marvel
movies x-men in 2000 which is the marvel
movie where kevin feige got his start as
an associate producer we're coming full
circle with that and i think there's a
deliberate reason for that i'll get to
it at the end of the video oh you cheese
using electrical towers meanwhile peter
uses a piece of wrist tech that
eliminates rings of eldritch magic from
doctor strange so must be this suit or
maybe even just this piece on his wrist
was probably given to peter in order to
snare villains like elektro kind of like
a ghostbuster using a proton pack and a
trap then dr strange tells them to
scooby-doo this crap just another
example the mcu folding in all of pop
culture into their universe kind of like
how eternals just cited other warner
properties like superman and batman and
then a preview clip of hawkeye mentioned
katniss everdeen from hunger games but
strange telling them to scooby-doo this
problem does cast this group as a kind
of mystery ink like mj would be velma
peter probably shaggy ned scooby and
happy and aunt mate fred and daphne
they're useless and always trying
why don't you mind your own [ __ ]
business
like in scooby doo the kids of this
movie might end up unmasking the real
villain behind it all which according to
red hair is more often than not the old
man jenkins who hired them in the first
place so just add this to the list of
reasons to be super suspicious of doctor
strange in this movie he may be the
witch who would have gotten away with it
if it weren't for that meddling nedlin
yeah honestly after watching this
trailer there were so many people who
thought like strangers acting weird from
that first teaser trailer but after
watching this one the footage here
everything's presented holds even more
credence towards the fact that there's
something up with doctor strange in this
movie there's something going on with it
could he be under control i don't think
it's mephisto maybe perhaps eric is
right about the wanda theory or maybe
they're just at odds you know
philosophical odds because clearly as
demonstrated in the trailer peter views
the situation with the villains of the
multiverse being one way and strange
views in a completely other context
maybe ends up conjuring up a good
conversation or like a debate for the
audience who's right in this situation
and maybe it lends itself to a learning
lesson who knows but there is something
up with him all right something seems
really suspicious i mean i think that a
parallel doctor strange imprisoned ours
and is masquerading that's that's my
theory so we see a combination of
electro and sandman attacking cops and
news vans but now standing inside the
daily bugle van is our man jk simmons as
j jonah jameson giddy smile on his face
as he realizes he's getting a great
scoop and as electro blasts away you can
see his humanoid shape flashing like
lightning from spot to spot now of
course his lightning color is now yellow
not blue like in the amazing spider-man
2 but since doc ock can absorb nanotech
i think a lot of these villains might
adapt new features as they transition
into the mcu
chilling us with this line you're flying
out into the darkness
to fight ghosts for one it doubles down
on this ghostbusters parallel of peter's
mission but also alfred molina is
looking directly into the camera here as
if this is how he shuts up those kids
for laughing about his name reminding
them that they will be facing mad men
who should be dead who now think that
they're in some kind of purgatory or
hell and therefore they have nothing to
lose doctor strange says that all these
people died fighting their version of
that true that definitely wasn't the
case for sandman at the end of
spider-man 3. peter parker forgave him
and let him go making us wonder geez
toby what did you do after spider-man 3.
did flynn marco break your damn door fix
this
i mean more than that he didn't kill doc
doc sacrificed himself i kind of don't
remember fully how the events happened
with electro and lizard to be totally
honest but i thought since there's
something with lizard being alive in a
post credit scene on my way off about
that either way the most direct one in
my opinion out of the ones returning is
green goblin yeah i mean because that's
the most personal that's yeah i was like
yeah he's definitely dead after this
they have a whole like father-son
archetype yeah send off with that and
then the rest of them are just you know
kind of
varying circumstances then peter leaps
after a pumpkin grenade as it explodes
in front of him this actually looks like
the lobby of that same building the one
with the police cars outside the same
one we later see a lecture on sandman
outside of in the lobby that aunt may
seems to be charging through i also
think based off of the swats forming
around it that is where happy hogan is
so ugh between happy and may that's two
very worrisome options for who this
pumpkin grenade may be targeting but
peter does seem to be wearing a new
incarnation of his iron spider nanotech
that probably protects him from this
explosion you can see that gold emblem
stretching across his shoulders that's
completely new the guy's got a million
suits in this franchise and in that shot
he appears to be talking to aunt may
after the explosion so i'm thinking
she'll be okay happy though i don't know
but an explosion does destroy the
entrance emitting a green fire which
actually continues to burn green on that
piece in the lower right so i'm
wondering if this would be part of
goblin's weaponry and then on the right
is a feast truck feast is peter parker's
homeless outreach organization and it
has a big hole torn out of the side of
the truck like someone might have used
this truck as perhaps a trojan horse
that they burst out in the attack okay
so that could be feast why would they
need to get into feast we don't know
what's located there maybe some
multiversal crap or maybe it's the mcu's
version of oscorp that's there
and that's why goblin led the way to get
his hands on some technology could be
maybe maybe aunt may was at feast and
they kidnapped her from there
why
why
to you know told the computer yeah that
makes sense i don't know why my mind did
not actually go there
i snapped up one of his loved ones to
get him up against the roof
or maybe they're just hungry deciding
that he does not want to send these
villains to their certain deaths either
realizing that if he's worthy of
redemption so must they be or after a
mysterio he doesn't want any villain
blood on his hands peter whips and
snatches that green cube artifact as it
levitates between strange's hands i'm
assuming this is some kind of pokeball
pocket prison that dr strange is either
storing the villains inside of or some
kind of mechanism that allows him to
return them to sender i love this peter
is strung between two portals strange
must have tricked peter by opening one
portal in the direction he was already
whipping and then another one
immediately behind him so that peter
ended up whipping his own foot genius
oh great such a question i did not
notice that oh holy crap that is so
awesome it's so quick but yeah how smart
oh he's literally whipping himself that
is genius
so
short but that's a cool sequence man guy
admire the creativity of that but in
this shot i mentioned before aunt may
looks super emotional and she's carrying
some device looks metallic cylindrical
and glowing green a bit so form of
goblin's tick then doc tries to crush
peter's head which then leads to the
nanobot spreading across his mechanical
arms this actually might have been a
defense mechanism by the nanobots to
keep the claws from crushing the helmet
but then those bots fused with otto's
neural link allowing him to inherit them
onto the next clip
you're not gonna take this away from me
peter
you're struggling
and
everything you want
while the world tries to make you choose
so peter swings through the scaffolding
at the base of the statue of liberty but
you'll notice the statue is bronze
colored not the green color we know
today and that's because when the statue
was originally assembled in france in
the 1880s its copper plating made it a
dull brown color and then over the next
30 years it oxidized green the color we
now know it as oh so maybe this statue
is actually restored as part of its
newest avenger redo actually in shots of
peter perched on the crown you could see
streaks of green in those spikes
sedation was being scrubbed off then we
get our first clear look at jamie box as
electro he wears this chunky gear that
seems to help conduct the electric
current and all seems to be stemming
from a chest component that almost looks
like an arc reactor like a spare one
from stark's tech just be another piece
of stark tech that one of these spidey
villains could hijack and repurpose he
does seem to fire a powerful blast it
seems like it's a mixture of repulsor
blasts and then i love this as the
electricity courses over his head it
makes the yellow starburst shape of
elektro's classic spark mast from the
comics actually if it is start tech
which i'm not a big fan of but the idea
of it if it is star tech maybe they're
breaking into a building that's that's
uh housing some of that oh yeah that has
like a stockpile or something like that
and maybe norman osborne knowing you
know being a tech and biology giant
anyway could reverse or you know
re-engineer re-engineers all that stuff
for all of them and it's all happening
at feast homeless center you'll never
suspect us here i mean there's something
here that eric didn't actually point out
that we noticed we were going frame by
frame with this in the live stream
yesterday because he's usually yellow
here but then there's this moment in the
trailer where he's actually like kind of
translucent here with the electricity
he's just his outline of sparks
and lightning yeah yeah and then he
he goes from blue into the yellow form
so this could be the first maybe it is
like the star tech thing that he the of
the arc reactor he puts in here that
allows for this fusion to happen to also
give him a nice looking haircut and make
him look buff instead of how max looked
an amazing spiderman too every arc
reactor comes with tony's attitude to
give you a makeover because this looks
like it could be from the statue of
liberty fight sure but i do find this
interesting how it's the way he's
responding to it seems like this is the
first time he's ever using this when you
look at his body and arms because yeah
you see him go from like translucent
blue like he's pretty much invisible to
flat out blue to now all yellow
i don't know what that means i was
hoping you would explain it
totally honestly then we get a nice
close-up of green goblin on his glider
as well as a quick flash of a goblin
without his helmet wearing flight
goggles i'm just thinking this is a
blurry willem dafoe face because if
alternate goblins or hobgoblin was in
this movie i don't think they would
reveal james franco ordained a han
goblin in a shot like this but you'll
notice he drops in with a swarm of razor
bats you remember those nasty things
from the first rainy film and then a
dodc swat unit swarms in on the building
department of damage control these are
the authorities who arrested interrogate
peter and they seem to hear it be in the
apparent aftermath of that green
explosion and then a juiced up version
of doctor strange's spell blast out from
liberty island expanding far into the
sky maybe that cube broke open causing
the barriers between realities to open
even wider more thoughts on this in a
bit but onto the next
this is all clip fault i can't save
everyone
okay so electro sandman's giant face and
lizard leap across the statue of liberty
scaffolding towards spider-man but
clearly lizard is jumping towards
something else that must be positioned
beneath spider-man that's been scrubbed
from the frame actually in the brazilian
version of this trailer the cut was left
long enough to show lizard recoiling as
if something kicked him in the head
something that was removed from this
trailer and i think it's a very good
chance that in the theatrical version of
the scene that is going to be andrew
garfield spider-man maybe toby maguire
spider-man but garfield peter has a
history with lizard actually elektra was
also an andrew peter villain sandman was
the toby peterville and tom's really the
odd one out here but this shot just
makes it seem like it's three versus one
but compositionally it makes far more
sense for this to be three versus three
kind of like how the profile collision
shot in civil war was equal numbers on
both sides and when peter tells aunt may
that he can't save everyone i think the
subtext to that is that he can't do it
alone and he's gonna get some in-game
style back up from his peter variants
now i fully respect for not putting toby
and andrew in the trailer but fans have
been so ravenous with speculation i
think it's a foregone conclusion at this
point still i think we're gonna scream
like doc brown when we see that yeah
yeah we can't wait for that moment i
mean another thing too is i don't think
peter is the kind of guy to go charging
in at least from what the
peter parker that i've come to know over
the years he wouldn't go charging it at
three villains like that especially in
that fashion yeah he would be smarter
more strategic about it you know that's
what usually leads him to getting his
ass kicked and then having to rethink
his plan yeah yeah just jumping at all
three of them seems like a great way to
get yourself smashed yeah so the giant
captain america shield crashes through
the scaffolding causing ned and mj to
lose their balance and mj falls in slow
motion with framing pretty similar to
gwen stacy's fault in the amazing
spider-man 2. peter dives after her
reaching out his hand is he going to
catch her while many are asking whose
hand this actually is it's definitely
tom holland peter parker's hand based on
the glove design in the new suit he is
wearing in the sequence but the
parallels to andrew garfield peter
parker and gwen stacy's death are pretty
strong enough here that it would not
surprise me if sony pulls another vfx
switcheroo and replaces tom's hand with
the life-saving grasp of
shrek i'm kidding andrew garfield who
would refuse to let another peter parker
love interest die the same way his gwen
stacy did you'll notice that the two
hands here are framed perfectly with one
world trade center in the background
just as this building does looming over
gwen stacy's funeral in the 2014 film
huh
neato see my thoughts on this because
the popular theory is that andrew
garfield would swoop in safer and get
redemption for uh what happened with
gwen stacy while i like that for angie
garfield's character i really like that
for tom holland's character peter parker
i feel like that would undercut him he
needs to save his woman
in that moment you know what i mean he
needs to save her he's already getting
so much help
let's save this romantic interest please
yeah with a movie that's already
throwing a bunch of themes at you about
how it's gonna be so hard for you to try
and balance both sides of your life and
all this stuff that you do as spider-man
is going to negatively impact the people
you love like it would undercut that
message for him to definitely be him to
save her yeah you get it johnny but eric
you didn't point out the thing that
everyone was been putting out here what
the second most talked about they got
our livestream right here at this moment
this
is the part
that looks like it should be a
spider-man or an andrew garfield
arm on pull being cgied out not well
blown off i don't know what this would
be and maybe i'm wrong but i'd like you
to acknowledge what this might be mr
ross it's your theory vos because i
think it's failed cgi out of spider-man
that's what it looks like to me i think
it's somebody losing their job at the
trailer company
so it looks as though that spell that
blasted outward from the statue of
liberty has left this crack in the sky
like the cracks in space formed when the
multiverse shattered in loki or the
shattering of reality walls and what if
now these cracks were once orange like
the golden bands of dr strange's spell
but now a purple glow has overtaken the
orange color as this glows in from what
lays beyond purple has tended to be the
color of dark magic in the mcu the color
of dormammu in the dark dimension the
color of agatha harkness is dark magic
but the question is
who has started to come in through these
cracks that doctor strange cannot keep
out well interdimensional threats like
dormammu or shumagorath or demons from
the what-if episode 4 always seemed to
be a threat to doctor strange maybe
we're looking at a symbiote hive or kang
variants i don't think it has to be one
big threat but like the sinister six
spawning throughout the mcu any number
of out of place outsiders suddenly
appearing from different universes and i
think it is interesting that they chose
the statue of liberty as the focal point
of all of this the gateway to a new
world for the title the poor the huddled
masses yearning to breathe free a symbol
chosen specifically for that x-men final
battle for that reason as part of
magneto's plan to transform worldviews
[ __ ] there you go where i think
regardless from a shining beacon in lady
liberty's torch no way home is clearly a
prelude to doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness which i'm pretty
sure is gonna be the mcu's version of
the scarlet witch house of the m
storyline which is the nexus point of
mutant existence in the multiverse if we
are seeing the moment that break in
reality occurs and if doctor strange has
any link whatsoever to the scarlet witch
which we know from one division that he
does then kevin feige might have chosen
the statue of liberty specifically for
that parallel symbolism as the place
that he when he got his start
and he could be now bringing it full
circle as a place mutant kind arrives on
the shores of the mcu wow so what's he
saying will arrive i guess mute
or the concept of the x gene
i love the idea of this is the start of
it like this is the catalyst that would
lead into all the crazy plot that
happens in multiverse and madness itself
like this is the prelude to it that
sounds great because all of us were
thinking that they're probably hinting
at toby and andrew and it sounds like
from trailer editing that he's still on
the villain side because i was thinking
that maybe doctor strange is if he is
possessed by wanda the way how you're
talking about it maybe if he is
possessed by wanda he's still on the
villain side and he's trying to prevent
toby and andrew from breaking through
mm-hmm i don't know i mean for me it
seems like it's just toby and andrew's
ass so is he really there
well that's what i wonder because for me
it would be kind of funny if it was just
i'm they're coming through just these
two spiderman and i can't keep these
just these two spiderman i i feel like
it has to be you see these giant cracks
there's probably a lot of different
things that could include the other
spider-man although if you're at this
point in the movie i feel like they
might have already had to be here so for
me it's more like just everyone from
every other universe kind of like he
alludes to from before
true you know then maybe that includes
some mutants but it seems like it would
be hard to be like hey
look mutants exist in the mcu all
because of this yeah you know i don't
think they're gonna go that far
but it could be the seed for it all
right guys yeah subscribe to new rock
stars man always killing the game check
out epic hero shop.com today so much
spiderman to talk about until its
release date thank you so much for being
here we'll catch you guys soon
you